bene partiamo da cappuccetto rosso vuole
conoscere la storia una ragazzina con il
cappuccio rosso deve andare dalla nonna
a portargli una torta preparata dalla
mamma a mamma se tanto raccomandata di
prendere l'unica strada l'unico sentiero
quello che porta dritto alla casa della
nonna ma appena comincia a entrare nel
sentiero la bambina curiosa cominci a
distrarsi vede un fungo poi vede solo
una farfalla che vola si sposta risposto
ancora si sposta ancora si sposta ancora
quando si gira il sentiero non c'è più
cominci aver paura scende la sera le
ombre nel bosco cominciano a sembrare
altro da quello che sono e si è persa si
è smarrita fermiamoci un attimo se fosse
andata dalla nonna ce la saremmo
raccontato la storia yo yo yo
raccontiamo proprio perché sbaglia
strada
noi siamo affascinati dall'idea che non
segue la strada giusta ma va nel bosco
se fosse andata la nonna sarebbe un
reality show
cioè si raccontano come quante quanti
miei figli hai messo dentro siamo una
lezione di cucina se va bene con tutti
quelli che si fanno in televisione tutti
i giorni e saremo e voi e che guardano
la banalità della vita ordinaria di
tutti i giorni fingendo che siano chissà
che cosa
e invece no invece c'è un'altra vita da
un'altra parte che è quella del bosco lo
è perché sentiamo dentro di noi che
tutto sommato quel bosco li e più
intrigante nella strada principale
noi sappiamo che quel bosco ci dice
molto di noi del nostro bosco del bosco
della vita delle ombre che abbiamo
dentro dei rischi perché molto rischioso
perdere la strada i rischi gli incontri
le possibilità di sviamento le
possibilità di perdersi è proseguita di
morire perdendo la strada
questo rischio però ci affascina ci
affascina tutto quello che non
corrisponde alla norma
che non ci non c è quello andiamo al
teatro per quello andiamo al cinema
perché lo leggiamo i romanzi tutte le
storie hanno a che fare con la
possibilità di non ripetere quello che
già conosciamo di andare verso qualche
altra cosa
bene cappuccetto rosso però la strada la
continua e a un certo punto incontra un
essere peloso molto peloso nella storia
sembra che lei non abbia mai visto un po
tanto che gli si avvicina il lupo
gigantesco poi nelle raffigurazioni
delle liste di distruzioni dell'infanzia
lo fanno veramente evidente fuori enorme
gigante e concetto e lo so si avvicina
al lupo lo guarda e quasi sta per
chiedergli qualcosa per sala strada per
andare
qual è la strada giusta e se pezzi per
almeno è un essere non è un essere umano
ma è un essere confrontarsi lupo
cappuccetto rosso sta qua e il lupo qua
perché non se la pappa subita e la sua
natura si gira atto boccone concetto che
se morta per ingoiata e la fiaba tribuna
morale avete visto non si deve mai
bisogna stare a sentire la mamma e
andare per la strada giusta
e invece no il lupo si gira e gli dice
facciamo un gioco e rave la linea non
corrisponde a nulla di quello che ci
aspettiamo cioè la fiaba è veramente il
territorio dell'inaspettato cioè il lupo
gli staff sta facendo un gesto che non
corrisponde a causa effetto non ha nulla
dell andamento lineare con cui ci
aspettiamo che le cose accadano non se
la mangia c'e la mangerà dopo però c'è
tutto un gioco da fare per avere dalla
nonna travestirsi travestirsi da un
complicatissimo c'è l'acqua da un
boccone voleva d'amore ti mangi curare
no no c'è tutto un un gioco e tanto bene
di te che facciamo un gioco è una parola
molto importante nella fiaba questo
questo momento bene io credo che l'arte
e la creazione artistica abbia a che
fare con il gesto del lupo
cioè che l'arte nasce quando riesci a
produrre l'inaspettato quando riesce a
scartare già nasce quando perdi la
strada è questa è la prima cosa ma la
seconda e quando riesci a far sì che il
tuo procedere accada attraverso cose
inaspettate ma inaspettate anche a te
che stai lavorando inaspettate anche
all'artista io credo che la stessa cosa
debba vedere anche perché riguarda
l'educazione e quindi l'arte e la
creazione hanno a che fare con quello
che noi non ci aspettiamo di poter
creare tutte nell'ottanta 9 faccio
l'esempio personale che tutto dopo
quando l'ho fatto aspettiamo a sud el 89
io per la prima volta mi sono seduto su
una sedia ma io al teatro verdi di
milano e mi sono messo a raccontare una
storia di nuovi eventi con l'ass
senza mai alzare dalla sedia era la
prima volta che accadeva
io ricordo dopo dieci minuti gli
spettatori e si giravano e che fame
senza alzare anche fatto che può essere
che vada avanti ancora così è stato
l'inizio di come poi è stato chiamato il
teatro di narrazione avuto successo
strepitoso anche celestini paolini tutti
quelli che hanno usato questa questa
forma quando io l'ho fatta non mi
aspettavo assolutamente che venisse
fuori una forma teatrale io l'avevo
fatto è che mi ero posto un problema il
problema era essenzialmente molto
semplice un pre economico cioè come si
fa ad andare in un teatro con sette luci
o quattro o due avere solo il proprio
corpo e la propria voce e riuscire a
tenere un ora e venti gli spettatori
questo era il mio
come vedete una rosa molto pratica molto
concreta poi dopo riflettuto che in
effetti quello che ho fatto in quel
momento è stato qualcosa simile al lupo
e come perché ho spostato da quel
momento in poi ho spostato però perché
c'era arrivato già da prima se devo
capire come ci sono arrivato e perché
per anni ha raccontato fiabe storie ai
bambini ci sono arrivato a cui la storia
per adulti perché avevo fatto tante
esperienze di raccontano i bambini avevo
visto che il racconto poteva tenere
potevo riuscire a ricordo a genova con
bambini disagiati
mi fecero proprio la proposta un bambini
dei quartieri più disagiati con le madri
che si prostituisce e padre che si
bucavano e eravamo in grado di
attenzione dicevano le insegnanti di 7
minuti e il mio esercizio a rivedersi
ogni volta riuscirò a fare 10 15 20 20 c
a 37 minuti di attenzione che per gli
insegnanti era lì ho imparato un sacco
di cose no ho imparato lì a causare ma
che adesso non mi voglio parlare del
tema della della narrazione anche se è
una tecnologia che oggi avete per la
rete che magia avveniristiche
meravigliose quelli che ci troviamo
tutti i giorni sotto mano ma c'è una
teca forse non era la tecnologia parola
parlata non so se la tecnologia è una
cosa così antica è scritta nel nostro
dna dai secoli dei secoli e che viene
pochissimo usata però anche questo
pochissimo io nei miei 13 25 più 38 p 13
anni di scuola
raramente ricordo che un insegnante mi
ha chiesto di raccontargli qualcosa ma
sempre chiesto di ripetere qualcosa di
fare il riassunto di qualcosa di fare
un'analisi di qualcosa di spiegare
qualcosa ma il racconto in quanto tale
molto poco usato raramente raramente ho
avuto qualcuno che fosse interessato
alle mie storie
perché un bambino a 7 anni c'è una marea
di storia da raccontare ha già provato
tutto il tradimento la violenza l'amore
l'eros assaggia tutto ma nessuno gli
chiede cosa storico perché non è
importante perché deve imparare a
diventare adulto e per imparare
diventerà to the usa per leggere
scrivere far di conto accedere accedere
quindi il il processo attraverso cui lo
spostamento che ok in quel momento avevo
fatto dall'occhio all'orecchio è stato
qualcosa di molto importante a livello
del teatro italiano perché da quel
momento in poi si privilegiava l'udito
invece della lista non c'era piu niente
da vedere ma c'era l'udito e che ed era
una cosa poi arrivati i reading 16
della letteratura e quindi abbiamo
azzeccato qualcosa che era nell'aria e
ciò che la gente forse aveva un troppo
pieno di immagini e poi a cominciare a
poterle produrre le immagini per quello
che accade nella narrazione è
esattamente questo che tu raccontando
mostri un invisibile che non c'è ognuno
si costruisce il suo nessuno di quelli
che ascolta vede esattamente le stesse
cose come al cinema ognuno si fà il suo
figlio bene il lupo quindi non sta lì
troviamo la fiaba perché quel centro il
lupo non stalli e arrivo anche al dunque
il lupo non sta lì per ingoiare
cappuccetto rosso stanley per sedurla
seduce vuol dire sviare quindi il lupo
sali per far sviare ancora di più
cappuccetto rosso non solo fargli
perdere la strada iniziale sviarlo
ulteriormente ora ex ducere educare vuol
dire portare via da sono molto simili le
due cose cioè i grandi maestri sono dei
grandi seduttori sempre volevo dire
prenderli dall'allievo e spostarlo gesù
faccio l'esempio più grandi dico che
tutti lo lasciava siddharta tutti noi di
grande con un esempio parlano raccontano
i due pescatori abbandonano le reti e
rosa di sviare portare via da e il
compito principale del vero maestro che
è diverso dall insegnante sono le
necessarie tutte e due questi maestri
non possono essere tanti devono essere
basarsi eccezionali mi auguro che ne
abbiate incontrato qualcuno io non ho
mai incontrato nessuno nella mia vita se
non quando ho cominciato a far teatro
perché nel teatro i maestri contano sono
quelli che ti insegnano come stare in
piedi il tempo l'uso del corpo eccetera
però a scuola
ormai è successo qualcuno era un po
maestro maestra po pochi invece gli
insegna anche sono quelli che ti
insegnano come vivere cioè le regole che
servono per evitare di soccombere in
questa società molto complesse e quindi
utilissimo sapere che la strada è questa
i maestri sono quelli che prendono le
devo esser opposta un'altra parte e
vanno verso un inaspettato
ignoto un insoluto anche a se stessi e
mettersi in gioco con l'allievo che fa
sì che il processo educativo avvenga non
c'è niente di peggio che i fitti gu
recenti maestre le 10 profezia di
celestino del pret a porter della del
pret a porter del di questa di questa
l'idea della new age di tutto questo
esoterismo facile non riesce su finti
maestri sono quelli che organizzano gli
incanti e le sorprese come un percorso
in tour turistico in realtà il vero
maestro
va dove non sa mario lodi don milani
gianni rodari quelli che abbiamo sentito
anche in italia ne abbiamo prodotti
tanti big di grandi maestri e quando
faccio teatro quando cominciò a lavorare
con un gruppo di attori io quello che
vorrei di cui mi piacerebbe occuparmi
non è la regia che mi interessa
realmente poco è la maestria
cioè mi interessa condurre quel gruppo a
scoprire le potenzialità che quel gruppo
a collettivamente coralmente
individualmente non c'è non sempre ci
riesco
ma succede sempre ci azzecco gli
esercizi giusti ci si riesce
ed è meraviglioso quello che accade
meraviglioso il processo perché il vero
processo di conoscenza del lavoro
teatrale avviene durante il percorso di
lavoro
però poi lo spettacolo si lo spettacolo
e la distillazione di tutto quello che
scoperta pubblico viene vedere lo
spettacolo vi piace non ci piace legge
nello spettacolo forse qualcosa di tutto
il processo che c'è stato prima ma se
venisse alle prove il pubblico penso che
seppure o pagasse linea le prove serve
molto di interessanti li vede veramente
cosa vuol dire creare ma vede anche la
disperazione perché ci sono momenti di
assoluta disperazione dentro uno
spettacolo teatrale
quando feci anni fa e non mi ricordo
quando insomma dal teatro di roma me
significa in cina
piazza d'italia di antonio tabucchi e
ancora vinto la prima parte e facendo in
pochissimo tempo
questo gruppo molto affiatato di attori
lavorano molto bene la prima parte fino
a metà del romanzo che già è difficile
mettere in romanzo mettere in teatro un
romanzo la facemmo è molto forte
visivamente con movimenti scenici e
l'uso del corpo di immagini molto bene
però erano arrivati solo a metà e
mancava tutta l'altra metà è che tutti
noi sapevamo che se avessimo e durava 37
minuti che la prima parte è serissimo ha
fatto altri 37 minuti come la prima
parte no non funziona la non perché il
pubblico avrebbe accettato lo stesso
però avrebbe lavorato sulla convenzione
che già vi avevamo dato cioè i primi 37
minuti erano la convenzione con cui
guardare quello spettacolo e questo
accade sempre nell'arte l'arte insegna
sempre come guardare qualsiasi opera
d'arte e per questa educativa ricetta la
percezione se sei un opera d'arte
dovendo quindi i primi 37 mila e allora
eravamo in un in pace durata tre giorni
mi ricordo non dormivo la notte lasciati
ma come andiamo avanti perché rifacciamo
uguale alla ai primi 37 venne antonio a
vederci per fortuna quei fratelli
italiani mi dicono paolo emilia vengono
a vedere la prima parte che avevo
montato entusiasta chiama e disse una
cosa che ci fece l'inaspettato del lupo
dice io cioè mi sono emozionato sono
stupito perché non mi aspettavo che le
mie creature che io ho sempre scritto
sempre visto sull'avaria si potessero
incarnare in quei corpi li io non ho mai
pensato che garibaldi i vari nomi dei
personaggi garibaldi non quello vero si
chiamava garibaldi il personale i vari
nomi fossero con quella faccia lì con
quel corpo alle quindi la sua emozione
era di vedere viventi delle cose che
aveva sempre immaginato viventi ma in
tutt'altro modo viventi sulla pagina
solitariamente come perché la lettura e
la scrittura è un fatto solitario
non è uno spettacolo dal vivo
si chiama spettacolo dal vivo perché
mentre stiamo lì siamo vivi tutte e due
no ci scherzate ma guardate che è
fondamentale da quando i terroristi
ceceni nel teatro dal dub rocca sono
entrati in teatro anche questa cosa non
c'è più in quel luogo sacro non è più
sacro adesso il bataclan non è più
sangue quello è l'unico posto diceva
cammino tra i posti dove si combatte la
morte all'ospedale il teatro e lo sport
bene in tutte e tre questa società del
posto novecento è riuscita
desacralizzare tutte e tre
purtroppo le olimpiadi di monaco e le
ospedale conduce bombardato dagli
alleati americani secondo vorrei un
quarto poi ci spiegheranno che errore
umano poteva essere quello lì
bene e allora anche quel luogo voglio
dire qui dice lazzaro non funziona più
non è più vero che si racconti di salvi
la vita non è detta arriva qualcuno e ti
sparano interessa raccontare quindi
quella cosa lì non è detto e allora noi
ci disse questa cosa di incarnare quella
sera in ordine e maria la mia compagna
poi c'era una drammaturgia con il gruppo
degli ater
ma scusa ma è anche quello che gli
spettatori si aspettano esattamente il
contrario si aspettano che noi
incarniamo i personaggi in di corpi cioè
l'opposto di quello che perché perché
per tabucchi era un fatto è emozionante
perché lui aveva scritto quindi lui
vedeva da scrittura adesso vede
un'incarnazione gli spettatori vengono e
sanno già che saranno incarnati di bis
in carnia molin
la seconda parte dello spettacolo tutti
i personaggi stavano seduti ed era pure
a fune
cioè parlavano era pratica moratorio
radiofonico con poche luci sul
personaggio che dicevano tutte le cose
delle battute dei personaggi però non
c'era piu movimento non c'era più azione
c'è più niente da vedere
e come se lavorando bisogna riuscire a
creare le condizioni per poter errare
allora dovendo parlare dell'essenzialità
dell'educare secondo me le rare
nel senso proprio il doppio ter poteva
che abbondare e commettere errori queste
sono le due cose che secondo me
permettono di compiere davvero un
processo educativo molto rischioso
perché non è detto che hai sempre le
soluzioni per rimediare agli errori però
gli incameri il vecchio proverbio nostro
che sbagliando si impara e vecchissimo è
vero ma nella solo nel momento in cui
accetti di poter imparare dall errore e
ci vuole molta capacità ci vuole molta
vigilanza per poter accettare che stai
sbagliando e far tesoro di quell'errore
quello che non sta facendo l'europa
adesso nei confronti del terrorismo sta
ripetendo cose vecchie non sta imparando
quello che sta succedendo è molto
difficile probabilmente vi lascio con
questa mia idea forte mia personale che
che che l'arte e la creazione e anche
all'educazione perché non scendo molto i
due termini sia abbia a che fare con
questa possibilità di errare ma ma come
di prevederlo cioè di non vi prevederlo
di di lavorare senza aspettative di non
giudicare di non stare in ascolto ho
sentito molto questa parola che lo stare
in ascolto sapere cosa succede quando a
qualcuno
stai davvero in ascolto di volo e sta
dicendo gli spinter ho più parole in
bocca
grazie